Hello everybody. Welcome in person and
online,
which is a reminder that if you'd like to ask a question, which of
course we welcome, because there are people online and this is being
live streamed, please come up to the microphone so the
folks who are not in the audience can be sure to hear you.
So, my name is Jennifer Grandis, and I have the pleasure
of chairing this session today. I was so thrilled
when I was invited by the meeting organizers and even
more excited about all the panelists, except of course myself,
and if you get excited about yourself it becomes kind of a problem in life.
So
we have three speakers,
who are distinguished, and the first
speaker, who is a friend of mine and I've gotten to know her over the last few
years working in some common areas.
But the first speaker is Dr. Sharon Savage, who's going to speak
about cancer and telomere disorders. But a little bit about Dr.
Savage as she makes her way up. She's the director of the Clinical
Genetics Branch and Clinical Director of the Division of Cancer Epidemiology
and Genetics at the National Cancer Institute.
She has been there for decades. She has stewarded large
longitudinal trials and really moved the needle on
inherited cancer disorders. She has specialized in the
Li-Fraumeni syndrome, resulting in
worldwide collections of data, practice-changing
paradigms, et cetera. And so welcome, Dr.
Savage, and I look forward to your talk.
Thanks. Thanks so much.
As Dr. Grandis just said, I'm very
excited for this session. I think it's nice to see this kind of
focus here
at
AACR. And let me see.
There we go.
Thanks. Okay. So I'm very excited to tell you
about the work of our own group and of others on
telomere biology disorders. And since I think this is a topic that's not
really been well-defined here
at AACR in the past, I wanted to start, first of all, is that I
have no disclosures. And just a quick overview as we think about
telomeres and telomere biology in carcinogenesis.
So telomeres really have two roles, at least, in
the carcinogenic process. So, as cells divide,
telomeres get shorter and shorter because the DNA polymerases can't
fully replicate the single-stranded DNA ends.
When telomeres reach a critically short length, either cellular senescence
or apoptosis are triggered and
that's sort of that. But in some settings, cells can upregulate
p53, Rb, other pathways, and continue to
divide despite having critically short telomeres.
There's also mechanisms where cells can increase activity of
telomerase, which extends telomeric ends, or use an
alternate lengthening of telomere measurement, a telomere-length lengthening,
and
continue to lengthen their telomeres, continue to divide,
accumulate somatic mutations, and send those cells down that
carcinogenic pathways. So, as a little bit more
background, when we think about germline telomere length, so
what I just talked about was in cancer cells.
Now we're talking about in the germline setting.
There are lots of epidemiology studies that have
looked at telomere length, whether it's in blood, buccal cells, a
few others, as well as single nucleotide polymorphisms or
common variants in association with telomere length that have found
a key role of telomeres in cancer etiology and
cardiovascular disease etiology.
And those are all people in the general population who, if you measure
their telomeres, they're going to be somewhere between that first and
99th percentile for telomere length.
And these are all common variants, more than 1% minor allele
frequency.
At the other end of the spectrum, which is actually something I'm not going to talk
about today, is what we're now calling cancer predisposition with long
telomeres. It's also called POT1 tumor predisposition
syndrome if there are germline mutations in POT1.
And these are people who have very rare
germline variants, who have long but functional telomeres,
and they're at increased risk of certain malignancies.
Most of them are solid cancers, but not all. There are some CLLs and AMLs.
So we're going to focus our time today here on
telomere biology disorders. So what do I mean when I'm talking
about a telomere biology disorder?
The first
described link between germline telomere
biology and disease was related to families
exactly like this one. This is a family in one of our studies, but as
you see, it's a classic X-linked recessive pedigree.
And studying families like this is where the
first discovery of germline mutations in dyskerin and very
short telomeres were made by Inderjeet Dokal's
group in the UK back in 1998, '99. And
this really set the stage for us understanding the
role of telomeres in
disease in people. So in addition to those X-linked
recessive cases, we know that these patients have this
classic mucocutaneous triad: abnormal nails, abnormal
skin pigmentation, and oral leukoplakia.
They also have very high rates of bone marrow failure, of liver
disease and pulmonary disease, and a host of other
complications. And I'm going to spend, of course, most of my time
talking about cancer in these populations, but I think it's important to
put this complexity up here,
and that's becauseUp until development of the
diagnostic test, which is flow cytometry
in lymphocytes measuring telomere length, we didn't really
understand what the true spectrum of what we now call telomere biology
disorders was.
So this is work where we showed that if you look at first to
99th percentile, so 99% of the population is going to have these
telomere lengths. But our patients with dyskeratosis congenita had
very short telomeres for their age.
Now, we and others were able to use telomere length instead
of that wide clinical spectrum and variable clinical phenotypes I very
quickly went over to show that there are many,
many other genes in people who have variants that are
associated with dyskeratosis congenita and related telomere
biology disorders. I recently reviewed all the literature, and it was
really hard in thinking about this from a gene variant curation perspective
because there's still a lack of functional data, but there are at least 15
genes that have variants that are associated
with telomere biology disorders.
The challenge with this disease now is, again,
because we've developed the diagnostic test, more people are
getting tested, especially those with bone marrow failure and pulmonary
fibrosis, and we now know that there are autosomal dominant
forms of the disease, autosomal recessive, some genes do both.
And we also have de novo occurrence of variants.
So this is where the field is now, and I put this
definition up because this I think is a really key component in,
again, differentiating those long telomere rare variant patients.
When I'm talking about a telomere biology disorder, we're talking about a
specific spectrum of diseases that is caused by telomere
dysfunction.
And the phenotypes of these patients result from limited stem cell
renewal that's induced by critically short telomeres.
But there are some patients who have telomere biology disorders who if you
measure their telomere lengths, the average telomere length comes into
a normal range, but the distribution is markedly skewed, and that's because their
telomeres are dysfunctional.
So this is a really important clinical and biologic
difference to make.
The other thing that we're going to go into next is looking at
the age at onset. So if you started back on this field 10, 20 years ago,
you're thinking about dyskeratosis congenita, the mucocutaneous triad, bone
marrow failure, really sick little kids. Okay.
As we've expanded our testing, telomere length and genetic testing, we
know now that there are isolated phenotypes, so pulmonary
fibrosis,
families, aplastic anemia, some liver disease families
where heterozygous variants and some of those same genes cause
disease. And so how do we sort of understand and
quantify what this really means?
I'm going to share next the data from our study
that is nested within our inherited bone marrow failure syndrome study that was
open to accrual back in 2001 and I think really shows the
importance of long-term studies of high-risk families.
So in addition to dyskeratosis congenita and telomere biology
disorders, this study also includes Fanconi anemia, Diamond-Blackfan anemia,
Shwachman-Diamond syndrome, and some others.
And we've really used this as a platform for gene discovery and for
phenotype characterization.
Within the TBDs, Marina Naivitch, who was a clinical fellow with me,
Neelam Giri, and Blanche Alter was the PI.
We looked at our study cohort of 231 patients
from 124 families. Ninety-one of those patients
were seen at the NIH Clinical Center. They came for an entire week.
They had very detailed clinical and molecular phenotyping.
And we asked the question,
can we quantify the genotype-phenotype relationships that the
clinicians who are seeing these patients kind of are recognizing?
Like, we could sort of tell you a sick little kid with that phenotype I told you,
their gene is most likely TINF2 recessive or
X-linked. Whereas the adults with pulmonary fibrosis as their sole
presentation are more likely to have heterozygous variants.
So we said, "Well, can we quantify that?
What does that actually look like numerically?" So
Marina looked at all of our patients, as I just showed,
and what this shows is,
again, what we already sort of knew clinically is that our patients who
had heterozygous variants had much better overall
survival,
but it's still then those patients who were either biallelic, X-linked,
or had TINF2 variants. And
the overall survival is still quite poor compared with the general
population. So we were able to quantify that overall the
median survival was about 52 years in our whole cohort, but you can
see the difference between the heterozygotes and the others,
where the median survival is only into the 30s.
And this has helped us kind of better quantify and understand and
counsel patients as to kind of what's next for them.
So now thinking about cancer and assessing cancer in this
cohort. When we first started on this, I will say,
and it still holds true, is that the cancers in the TBDs are very much like
the cancers in Fanconi anemia, and I'll just put it out there, they do the
same with treatment, and that's not good. Okay.
We've quantified over many, many years, and in 2018,
we published 15-year follow-up of our cohort, and you can see that
prior to transplant, the risk of cancer was about four-fold
compared with the general population with really high risks for tongue squamous
cell cancer, AML, and MDS. And those risks seem to go up after
bone marrow transplant, which you might expect.Now,
Marina said, "Let's look at our cohort now that
we have more patients, we have more genetic information, we've
defined the gene in more patients and let's look prior to
transplant and after transplant." And when I
say transplant now, I'm not just talking about bone marrow, I'm also talking
about lung and liver because we had a handful of patients and we grouped all
transplanted patients together.
So if you look at our entire cohort, the risk of cancer compared with the
age, sex, cohort,
generational matching, all of that good stuff, the risk of
cancer is about three-fold higher than in the general population.
But what's really remarkable is just as we see those clinically
severe phenotypes, early onset marrow failure, immunodeficiency,
we also see high cancers, a difference in the
heterozygotes versus the biallelics in their cancer
risks. And I will add that with TINF2, we look at
this separately because even though they're all heterozygotes,
they tend to present very early in life and they have very
dysfunctional telomeres, and most of them have bone marrow failure and
that's why there's really only one patient who was in
our pre-transplant study.
Now, the most common solid tumor in TBDs is head
and neck squamous cell carcinoma.
It's HPV negative, tends to be in the oral cavity just like
Fanconi anemia. When we looked prior to transplant, the risk was about
50-fold higher than in the general population.
And you can see it goes way high after transplant.
Even if you knock these numbers down a bit because of sample size issues, it's
still incredibly high risks of cancer.
And we were able to kind of tease apart some of the differences in
that our biallelic patients had much more higher
risks and our TIN2, the one thing I want to point out here is that
our patients who have TIN2 mutations, the risks are incredibly
high for head and neck squamous cell.
And look at this median age, 14.7.
How many head and neck cancer docs have seen
a teenager with a head and neck cancer?
So this is really important data to help us figure out how to
screen and advance this
area. Next, we looked at AML and
MDS, and I'm just showing the prior to
transplant data. For obvious reasons, we didn't have enough to look at,
say, donor-derived leukemia.
But when we look, the risk of AML is again around 50-fold
higher than the general population. MDS, around 500.
Again, with some caveats that these are relatively small numbers.
But again, you see some subtle differences in the
dominant versus recessive or the heterozygote versus the biallelic patients,
but still very high risks of hematopoietic
cancers in this population.
So what's happening in the blood of these patients?
So one of the things that we and others have looked at is somatic rescue.
So this is a really nice review if anyone's interested in learning more,
where
what we see in patients with TBDs is both direct and
indirect hematopoietic rescue, where by direct I mean
basically a back mutation of the disease-causing gene.
And indirect, we have compensatory mutations that help
improve the hematopoietic phenotype, for example, with a TERT
promoter mutation.
In collaboration with the National Heart, Lung, and Blood
Institute cohort and a cohort in Sao Paulo, Brazil,
we showed that the acquisition of somatic mutations in
our patients with TBDs was associated with the
clinical outcomes. So patients who
had clonal hematopoiesis that was not associated with cancer
had mutations in POT1, in the TERT promoter, and in
PPM1D. And then those that were associated with the development of
cancer were, as you might expect, loss of P53,
MDM4 overexpression, U2AF1 mutations.
And just to sort of summarize that part of
the somatic mutation piece is
that telomere dysfunction appears to be a strong selective
pressure for clonal hematopoiesis.
It appears to be a poor prognostic marker, again though, depending on
which mutation you have. And that we're really working
hard as a field to identify the regulatory pathways that's
driving this clonal transformation in TBDs so that we can identify
patients who are at risk of cancer development.
And this is key because
a lot of these patients have bone marrow failure.
Just because they have bone marrow failure doesn't always mean they need a
transplant.
But you want to be able to monitor them and intervene early if it looks
like their counts are going down and/or they're acquiring
one of these somatic mutations, so then you can transplant them earlier.
And with a clinical care consortium, we are combining
retrospective data across around 600 or
700 patients around the world, and also working towards a
prospective study to get more information on
how to identify and better monitor the
acquisition of somatic mutations in these patients.
So I mentioned very briefly, a lot of our patients who
present in childhood have immunodeficiency, and in fact some of our
TINF2, our biallelic RTEL1 patients, our biallelic
TERT patients, actually can present in infancy or as toddlers
with very difficult to diagnose immunodeficiencies.
So there's been a couple papers just in the last year or so
that have started to really try to define the immune profile of telomere biology
disorders. And what we're finding is that there is reduced thymic
output, abnormal maturation of
lymphocytes, exhaustion of T lymphocytes,
unconventional T cells, pro-inflammatory profiles.
There's a lymphopenia.That is associated with the
immunodeficiency. And I didn't have time to put it here,
so these studies had really focused on T cells.
We have some really interesting data that we're kind of sorting through,
suggesting there's also a B cell defect.
So this is a model that I recently developed of
thinking of carcinogenesis in the telomere biology disorders.
And again, in these TBDs, we have really two
things going on. One is we have some patients who have germline
variants that prevent telomerase from doing its job, so
they're preventing telomere elongation.
And this happens in utero, so these are patients who are born
with really, really short telomeres. Okay?
It's not an accelerated shortening, it's just their set point is way lower
than it should be. So some patients, telomerase can't do its
job. Other patients, like our shelterin complex mutations,
TENF2 is one I've mentioned a lot, it's the most common shelterin
mutation, actually can't protect their telomeres.
So telomerase might be there trying to do its job, but there's no protection at
those chromosome ends. So they have these short
and/or unstable telomeres that can lead to an
accumulation of mutations, genomic instability, and then we're just
getting at some of the data that's suggesting that there's suboptimal immune
surveillance, at least looking at how we're
characterizing the immune deficiency in these patients.
Ongoing oxidative stress, because it's this sort of vicious cycle of
abnormal DNA repair, oxidative
phosphorylation, getting active and
producing reactive oxygen species, et cetera, and then we're
developing cancer. There's a lot of pieces there that we either don't know
or I haven't had a chance to describe in detail, but I kind of wanted to put this
concept out there.
So about treating cancers, what do we do with these patients who do
develop cancers? The short answer is we don't really know,
unfortunately. There's no clinical trial data.
I recently did a literature review where I found 25
cases in the literature that had at least some kind of
information about cancer treatment, and it was
all very dismal in that doses were adjusted, outcomes were
still poor,
side effects were really bad.
And when we looked just in our cohort, which is very limited, and the
timer's not working correctly, so I'm guessing.
Sorry.
I looked at our cohort data. Now this is very much a
descriptive snapshot,
and it's a study that we're just wanting to kind of get
together. But when we looked at six patients who had AML in our cohort,
and unfortunately, all of them died due to disease.
And they were really
not good deaths, very toxic, very complicated
patients. Two patients with non-Hodgkin lymphoma died within a
year of diagnosis.
One outcome was unknown. We've had some patients treated with
rituximab for PTLD after transplant who have done okay, but we
don't have really complete outcome data.
When I looked specifically in our cohort at head and neck squamous cell cancers,
you can see 21 cancers in only 11 patients.
One patient who had a TERT heterozygous mutation had
11 resections, and unfortunately, she passed away from head
and neck cancer just two years ago.
Three patients with one resection each.
We had patients with seven invasive cancers, and unfortunately for all
of these seven patients, one is unknown, and
unfortunately, the outcomes were very poor for the other six.
So what can we do right now? I think I'm pointing out all kinds of
questions in cancer in the TBDs. And what we have right
now is based on sort of expert opinion across the field,
built in our clinical care guidelines, which is screening, early
detection, trying to get our patients into the
otolaryngologist who actually is willing to see a
kid for a cancer screening, okay? That's a challenge for
our families, too.
Educating their dentists, their ENTs, following their
physical exams, doing all those good things that we're supposed to
be doing or not doing in preventing cancer in the general
population. So avoiding sun, avoiding smoking,
all of HPV vaccines as well.
And I will end there and just say that very recently,
Dr. Richa Sharma, who's a new investigator at the Cleveland Clinic,
has initiated a national DNA repair and telomere biology disorder
tumor board. It's separate from the Fanconi anemia
tumor board, and
we've had two meetings so far. They've been great, and if you have
cases you want to share, please send them to us.
That's the QR code, and here's the QR code for the TBD diagnosis
and management guidelines, and I'm happy to talk with anyone at any time, and I
really just want to acknowledge Doctors Giri and Naidich for
amazing work over all of these years. Thank you.
Okay, we have time for some questions. Please come up to the microphone.
Hi, Sharon. Clara Maxwell from Penn. Beautiful overview.
This is not a patient population I see, so excuse my naive question.
I'm wondering if with Fanconi anemia, we often think, "Okay, that's a very
phenotypic person. Their blood is negative.
We'll do a skin punch for the somatic reversion." For the telomere
biology disorders where there's not as obvious a phenotype-
Yeah
... what threshold do you think that people should then be considering the somatic
reversion?
So that's a really good question because somatic reversion is something that's only
been recently described over the last couple of years in these
patients. We used to think it was sort of rare, and now we're doing more and
we're seeing more. And so for the younger patients who tend to
have the phenotypes, you can still do a clinical diagnosis without telomere
length. We still will do telomere length even in adult patients who we
think may have reverted because usually their telomeres haven't recovered.
The challenge is, though, a lot of those patients are at the first to tenth
percentile for telomere length, which as I remind folks,
10% of the population is going to have telomeres at the 10th percentile.
So that's where genetic testing and panel testing
is really the next step in skin biopsies. Yeah.
Sharon, do you think it's really
right to put POT1 in this category with the long
telomeres, all kinds of wacky data that-
Yeah
... others are seeing where you inherit the telomere length from parents and then
the phenotype.
We're seeing this from another...
There's a huge bias to the ascertainment.
We're biased picking these up as incidentals in an adult cancer
center.
Yeah. So, the question really is around POT1.
So
from what I've seen so far is there's a set of heterozygous
POT1 mutations that are associated with long telomeres.
The molecular data suggests they're all functional, they're just long,
and those 10 so far have been in adults.
There are only a couple of case reports of POT1
causing a telomere biology disorder as I just described it, those are
more likely to be biallelic patients.
One thing that we don't know is which mutations
in POT1 are predisposing to what, and I think that's going to
be a next set. So,
Dirk Hockemeyer, who's at Berkeley, is doing a whole panel and basically
trying to map out the entire gene. And I think in the
end, POT1 is probably going to be one of those long
telomere cancer predispositions and very, very rarely will
cause a really truly dysfunctional telomere.
Yeah.
Thank you, Sharon.
Okay. Thank you.
So we're going to switch gears slightly, a different part of
the body. And Dr. Faye Kastrinos is a national leader in
GI cancer. She's a gastroenterologist, professor of medicine at
Columbia, and the director of the GI Cancer Genetics and Prevention
Program. Her research has really focused on genetic risk
assessment in individuals with Lynch syndrome.
We're going to hear a little bit about more today, and her work has really
translated into the clinic in a validated prem
model that allows clinicians to help individuals to
predict their actual risk of developing a colon cancer. Welcome, Dr.
Kastrinos.
Thank you everyone for joining us this afternoon, and I'd like to thank the
organizers for the opportunity to speak today.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
We're going to start off today by talking about the optimal identification of Lynch
syndrome, individuals who are carriers, delve into the
genotype-specific cancer risks associated with Lynch syndrome, and then the
implications that genotype prevalence and risk has on how we
manage patients with a focus specifically on colorectal
cancer screening. And lastly, we're going to talk about some considerations as we
integrate new biomarkers into cancer
screening. So a little bit about Lynch syndrome.
It's the most common inherited GI cancer syndrome. It's autosomal dominant.
The canonical cancers include colorectal and endometrial cancer.
It's common.
I'm going to say that again. It's common.
Its prevalence is 1 in 350, similar to
BRCA hereditary breast and ovarian cancer syndrome.
We don't get as much publicity, we don't speak about Lynch syndrome, and
it kind of is underappreciated and recognized, but it is
very common. Mismatch repair deficiency is a hallmark
feature, so the MSI-high phenotype is very important as it has
been much so with immunotherapy.
And we're discovering more patients with Lynch syndrome because of the
treatment options. But universal screening specific
to Lynch syndrome now has been recommended for almost a decade and
a half in all colorectal cancers and all endometrial
cancers that they're screened by IHC for mismatch
repair loss. And then we'll talk about and hone in on
the genotype variation in cancer risk of the
four mismatch repair genes shown here. So what are the benefits?
I mentioned already the therapeutic, but also surgical decision-making that
goes into identifying individuals with Lynch syndrome.
There's surveillance of cancers after a primary cancer has been diagnosed, but
also screening for associated cancers and even
offering risk-reducing surgeries specific to women who
benefit most from risk-reducing
surgeries as well. Screening and genetic testing of
families, so a big at-risk pool of individuals, many
of whom are unaffected by cancer, and we offer them the opportunity
for prevention. Reproductive counseling, so in patients who
are undergoing IVF, the consideration for preimplantation genetic
diagnosis. Chemoprevention, aspirin, long-term aspirin
use has been shown to decrease
colorectal neoplasia incidence.
And then very exciting studies that are underway, trials looking at
immunoprevention and vaccines specific to Lynch
syndrome.So these are the malignancies associated with
Lynch. As you can see, they are numerous, and there's quite a variation between men
and women, but also by the genotypes as shown here.
Colorectal cancer, the most common, as well as
endometrial. But as gastroenterologists, we're also very
much aware of GI-associated malignancies for which we offer screening, including
gastric and then hepatobiliary and pancreatic.
I want to focus in also on urinary tract tumors, which are very common in
both men and women, and exciting work looking at MSI as
a biomarker in urine specimens.
Presented in another way, just to show
the burden of all these cancers in mutation carriers.
Here, stratified by the type of germline alteration.
We could see what the burden of cancer is on these individuals.
The MSH2
noted most to have a lot of extra colonic
tumors associated with it, followed by MLH1.
More colon cancers in MLH1, extra colonics in
MSH2. And then what's really striking is the PMS2
carriers have a very low rate of malignancy overall,
even colorectal cancer.
So in honing in on how to best identify individuals with Lynch
syndrome, I'm going to focus on three populations of interest.
Those with cancer, those high-risk individuals unaffected by
cancer but whose families carry a pathogenic variant, those with
family history, and then assessing for Lynch syndrome in the general population.
So this is a really nice study done by a colleague at Memorial,
Sofia Stadler's group, that looked at the prevalence of Lynch syndrome across
solid tumors that
looked at microsatellite instability.
And as expected, MSI-high is predictive of Lynch syndrome with the majority of
MSI tumors or Lynch syndrome carriers identified in those with
MSI-high. And here you could see, again, the canonical cancers are
represented here, mostly colorectal.
But then very small prevalence of Lynch syndrome in microsatellite
intermediate and microsatellite stable tumors.
So it's safe to say that germline testing should be recommended for
all those with MSI-high tumors, regardless of their cancer type, as we
can see here. But I also want to point out
here below that some of these mutation carriers
had tumors that were microsatellite intermediate or
stable and would have been missed if we only focused on MSI-high
tumors.
I am in favor of when we're looking at tumors and next generation
sequencing, that we're also parallel doing germline testing to
capture all individuals with Lynch syndrome.
If we look at individuals with colon cancer unselected
by their tumor phenotype, also
irrespective of their family history, if we were to stratify
those diagnosed at less than 50 with colorectal cancer, we could see that
10% is diagnosed with Lynch. But the super young,
the very young, less than 35, about a quarter of those colon cancer
cases are going to be Lynch syndrome followed by polyposis.
Looking at it in the opposite direction of those who are greater than 50,
we see less of a prevalence of the inherited germline alterations of Lynch and
polyposis, but we see this higher other category.
And these individuals were detected on multi-gene panel testing.
And these are the other pathogenic variants, and I show
here the highly penetrant ones. So identifying colon cancer
patients with these variants offers them the opportunity for
other personalized screening, but also to the at-risk family members that
would benefit.
That's a good segue into the next population of interest, identifying
Lynch syndrome in individuals without cancer.
So pre-virus are those individuals without cancer who carry a pathogenic variant.
The one way to diagnose it is to improve cascade testing.
So when a pathogenic variant is already known in the family, when someone carries
an MSH2, let's say,
variant because they had endometrial cancer offering at-risk relatives
germline testing for that specific alteration, but also the ability
to perform risk assessment based on family cancer history.
So this is just in better understanding the magnitude
of germline testing and cascade testing.
If we had these two individuals both affected by colorectal
cancer who were known to be Lynch syndrome, this is the burden
of potentially,
these are the at-risk relatives. And we could see there's a lot to be gained
from germline testing in these individuals, where if you were to offer this
generation germline testing, it would inform future generations
and they would participate again in screening opportunities.
You would think that this is a slam dunk. It can't be easier than that.
You know there's Lynch syndrome in the 50, but the uptake of cascade testing at
best is only 40%.
We wanted to quantify what kind of benefit
one would
appreciate first-degree relatives if they were tested, and then
the benefits of cancer screening.
We focused here specifically on colorectal cancer.
So here we have the proband who was diagnosed with colon cancer at age 50,
known to carry a pathogenic variant.
So if a child came in, what would be the benefit?
What would they gain from knowing their genotype?
And here we could see, and this is based on microsimulation modeling.
You would see here that the benefit of undergoing cascade
testing and participating in appropriate screening would
decrease their development of cancer by at least
16%.
What does that mean if a sibling were to come in for cascade testing and
found to be a new Lynch carrier? Their benefit from participating in
screening would decrease their cancer development by about
9%. And even the older patient, that parent, it could be
either one, that
was the obligate carrier. Even genotyping them and having them
participate in screening would decrease the development of
cancer.Here I'm just showing how
participating in cascade testing with increased participation, more
individuals undergoing cascade testing where adherence is uptake of
cascade testing. We see very clearly how many
cancer deaths could be averted,
most often in the young, but not insignificant in older
patients too. So the benefits of screening once finding out
you're a Lynch syndrome carrier. As I mentioned, the uptake is
low, about 20% to 40%. It relies on family
communication and the perception of risk.
There's limited access to genetic counseling and trying to better understand what
these barriers are. I think our current delivery model is a limiting
factor. For that patient newly diagnosed with
cancer and found to be a Lynch syndrome carrier, they meet a genetic
counselor, and that's kind of their one visit, and then they're left to really deal
with their cancer diagnosis. So that opportunity to follow up with the genetic
counselor for that patient and family members might be a small
window, and that cascade testing is not frequently readdressed.
Once cancer treatment is focused on,
there isn't much of a readdressing as to did your kids get
germline testing. That's where I think the gastroenterology
community could do better because we're screening these individuals, some on
a near annual basis, and I really do think we need to do better
in identifying and readdressing the importance of germline
testing and asking them as part of their annual visit
what relatives were tested. In
better appreciating the burden of cancer and whether it's Lynch, we had
developed a prediction model, the PREM5 model,
which estimates a cumulative probability that an individual carries one of the
mismatch repair genes. This was based on a logistic regression
analysis. It was made possible by actually mining large
data sets from two
genetics companies, Myriad and Ambry Genetics, and then extensive
validation with the International Mismatch Repair
Consortium and the CCFR. It focused only on
proband and family cancer history, and I was happy to see it
initially put into guidelines in 2004 as its
iterations went from MLH1, MSH2, then
PREM126 when
MSH6 was included, and then with PMS2
PREM5.
So this is just a sample of what the online tool
looks like. Very easy. It was intended for healthcare providers, but patients can
fill this out, assessing patient information, their current age,
their sex, their cancer type specific, and mostly weighing in on the
canonical cancers, but also some of the Lynch syndrome-associated
cancers in first-degree and as well as second-degree.
Very
detailed questions. And then it generates a percent likelihood that
someone carries the mismatch repair gene.
And the overall predicted value of
equal or greater than 2.5% warrants germline genetic
evaluation and testing. And I'm happy to say that
insurance carriers cover germline testing based on the output from the PREM
score.
Switching now to what the potential
impact that population-based germline testing may have.
So the CDC's Office of Public Health Genomics identifies these
three conditions here on the bottom as Tier One conditions
for which germline testing could be performed in the general
population as a risk assessment tool for these conditions
which are common and also have a high penetrance.
Noting that participating in screening or risk-reducing surgeries
could have a positive impact on public health.
But also noticing that these conditions were deemed poorly ascertained by the
healthcare system, and many individuals and families might not be
aware that they are at risk. And it's estimated in the United States that about a
million individuals have Lynch syndrome and don't know that they do.
This prompted us to look at kind of the population burden of
Lynch syndrome in the United States and looking at data from the All of Us Research
Initiative,
which you may know is a population-based cohort of a million subjects that all
underwent
whole genome sequencing. And we analyzed the initial
slew of data of over 200,000 individuals to assess
the prevalence of Lynch syndrome.
Again, one in 354. When
looking at personal and family cancer history, we see here that
63% did not report a cancer
history consistent with Lynch syndrome in family members or of their own.
So that diagnosis
would have been missed altogether by our existing clinical criteria.
So these findings really support consideration of population
germline testing. And I also want to focus here on the
distribution of the pathogenic variants.
MLH1 and MSH2, for the longest time, they were the first genes
identified with Lynch syndrome in the early 2000s, and for
which our screening guidelines mostly focused in on the stronger of
the phenotype. But we see here in this
population-based cohort that the majority of germline carriers
with Lynch syndrome have the weaker phenotype of MSH6 and
PMS2.
In that study, we also looked at
cancer in Lynch syndrome carriers relative to those that
were non-carriers. The black line is the non-carrier
status. If we took all cancers, irrespective of them being Lynch
syndrome associated, we see that they're pretty parallel until later
on, probably 65 and later. And here are the associations.
Still higher in Lynch syndrome carriers.
If we stratified and only looked at the Lynch syndrome-associated cancers, we
see that by the late 30s, we start deviating where carriers
have a higher frequency of cancers
compared to the general population, 26% compared to
18% at age 50, and then 93% to 75%
at age 70. This is an important
figurewhere we looked at the information by
genotype. The red line is MLH1, the strongest of the
Lynch syndrome phenotypes, and very heavy on the colon
cancer diagnosis, followed by MSH2.
MSH6 and PMS2 hover at
about, I would say, 40 for MSH6, but for
PMS2, we really don't see the cancer risks deviating
until after age 60. But then after age 60, they
catch up to the other genotypes.
So I think that's really important to consider, especially when we're making
guideline recommendations for screening.
And this is just looking at the distribution of
genotypes over the last 15 years. In this study published in
2011,
we could see how the predominance in all the
information coming on the genotype-phenotype correlations were focused on
MLH1 and MSH2. The PLSD
consortium is European-based only.
They're family registries from a number of countries that have been pooled together
for data. And here we could see the lesser phenotypes
creeping in. The International Mismatch Repair Consortium,
led by investigators in Australia, where we all sent our
information.
The US contributed mostly to
providing data on MSH6 and PMS2. And then I want to highlight
the last two. We spoke about the All of Us study and how much of a
predominance there is here of the weaker phenotypes, but this was presented in
abstract form at a conference which looked at data from the UK
Biobank, which looks similar, comes closer to what we
are seeing here in the United States.
And this is just from, again, the European consortium, which I
mentioned, and here you could see the striking difference, particularly in
PMS2.
So what does that mean? In focusing on colorectal cancer,
colonoscopy is the screening modality recommended for colon
cancer prevention.
In individuals,
that lifetime burden of colonoscopy could be anywhere
from 30 to 50 colonoscopies in their lifetime.
We start screening in two of the genotypes at age
25, so by the time you're finished with having your colonoscopy, you have to book
your next one for the following year, and we're looking at 50
years' worth of colonoscopy for certain carriers.
Obviously, it's invasive. Because
of a lot of burden associated with colonoscopy,
there's also non-adherence. Real life happens to our younger
Lynch syndrome patients. They have jobs, they have families, they have children.
So patients do fall out of their routine screening.
And here you could see there's also a financial toxicity that is very real that we
see with our patients. Interval cancers can happen, not just because someone
isn't on the right surveillance or they're missed, but also the biology.
In MLH1, there's some thought that the cancer
isn't progressing through the adenoma
pathway. And I also want to highlight that the genotype-specific
recommendations in the practice may vary.
This prompted us to do another modeling study looking at
genotype-specific cancer recommendations based on genotype.
Knowing that the prevalence is very different,
having limited data in the United States and all our guidelines really
being
that data coming in from other countries, we wanted to see
genotype-specific recommendations here.
And for MLH1 and MSH2, starting at age 25 with
colonoscopy every one year for MLH1, which is the stronger of the phenotypes.
Every two years in MSH2, and then the
big difference here is the age of initiation for
MSH6 was bumped up to age 35 and to
age 40 for PMS2, and the intervals
also creeping up to three years. Again, the prevalence,
but also the cancer risks that we have been able to generate
over years as more PMS2 and MSH6 carriers are
identified. So these, I put this together.
It was happy for me to see this actually printed out,
because these are the NCCN guidelines and how they've evolved over time.
So not that long ago, up until 2019,
the guidelines were the same for all genotypes and that colonoscopy was
recommended on an annual basis, one to two years.
In 2021, around the time that we published our paper, there was a
deviation where MSH6 and PMS2, later age of onset,
and again, the widening of the surveillance intervals.
And we see that carrying through until the most current
version of NCCN guidelines.
Here we are in the US with NCCN guidelines here, but
the rest are European guidelines, and you could see variation
in some saying one to two, some saying two, but
strikingly, some are saying five, and the varied practices
are seen
across Europe. So we're getting better at looking at
genotype and personalizing that screening.
Which brings me to the next part,
the real-world considerations, because we want to effectively screen
individuals, and now that we have a growing pool of newly identified
carriers, if we optimally identify them, and with a
lot more multigene panel testing done, we're going to have more carriers that are
going to be eligible for screening.
So getting these guidelines right matters.
I think it's important for us to assess available resources for this larger pool of
carriers, and I would caution about resource-intensive interventions in
areas with under-resourced systems,
but also appropriate allocation of what we do have to the genotypes that would
benefit the most.And lastly, very important, I
think our methods, and what we recommend for screening with
newer technologies, that we're mindful not to exacerbate any
health inequities.
So where does that bring us? I envision a multimodal screening
approach to Lynch syndrome, where we integrate non-invasive
tests to complement
our colonoscopy and other endoscopies that we perform in these individuals.
But the challenge is that the performance characteristics of novel
biomarkers, and even not so novel biomarkers like
stool-based colon cancer screening, haven't been assessed in
Lynch syndrome. So we don't know how these tests
perform. And because of that, they're currently not
incorporated in any protocols. The exclusion criteria has
excluded Lynch syndrome from all these newer screening modalities.
The current modalities under consideration and where we have plenty of work to do,
is looking at stool versus now blood-based single
cancer and multi-cancer early detection tests.
And I'm just going to
really talk briefly about this. This is us using modeling again
and incorporating non-invasive tests.
Here we've incorporated FIT, so fecal immunochemical
testing, which is at population levels utilized for colon cancer
screening, and comparing an interdigitating FIT.
We also modeled this to include multi-target stool DNA, but FIT
dominated, and multi-target stool DNA was very
expensive, prohibitively expensive.
So this is the recommendation focusing on PMS2, because I think this
genotype has the most to benefit from
less colonoscopy and more non-invasive.
Here we see colon cancer incidence creeping up, but we see the
quality-adjusted life years improving
with less colonoscopy for individuals.
By incorporating FIT, we see a decrease a little bit in the incidence while
preserving, again, that quality.
If we further go out to four years, we see an increase
in the incidence.
But if you were to
do a colonoscopy every four years and interdigitate
FIT, we see that it brings down the incidence and again, preserves
the highest quality. When we look at real-world practice, the
65% adherence to colonoscopy is actually what
is reported in Lynch syndrome. We don't have 100% adherence
to screening. This is modeled on 100%.
When we ran it at 65% adherence, we see that this
approach of colonoscopy every four years with a two-year FIT
was actually cost-effective as well.
Future integration, we need to assess the performance of these novel biomarkers
in Lynch.
We focus on modeling, and how we can interdigitate it, but
we really do need to know what the performance is.
It really impacts, as I've shown you, surveillance intervals.
I think it has the potential, these technologies, to capture interval
cancers,
but it could definitely be used to address our stop and start
dates of when to initiate and stop screening,
which can pose a huge burden.
Also using these novel tests, non-invasive blood-based biomarkers as a risk
stratification tool, because as I showed you earlier, there are many
extracolonic malignancies for our carriers.
So in conclusion,
we've talked about improved manners in identifying Lynch syndrome, and I
foresee that we're going to have an increasing pool of new carriers.
So really an unprecedented window of prevention.
And again, I want to highlight
the trials focusing on vaccines as
well. The integration of emerging biomarkers for a more
personalized genotype-specific recommendations that we make.
We have a lot of work to look at their clinical utility, their cost-effectiveness,
and how to integrate them. And then these ongoing collaborative
initiatives globally and with partners.
And lastly, to focus also on health equity.
There are a number of people I would like to thank.
The modeling groups, both for
the modeling cancer and screening.
Also the Prem team, and then the number of Lynch registries that we've had the
opportunity to collaborate with. Thank you.
We have time for one question.
One more.
So I'm really intrigued by the positive aspirin data, and I was
wondering, given the recent evidence in colorectal cancer, do you see
any association with PI3 kinase altered lesions
and the impact of aspirin? And then how has aspirin impacted...
How prevalent is it that people are taking aspirin and doesn't change your
algorithm for screening?
So this is a good question.
I want to say that the US hasn't participated in the
CAPS data. The aspirin dosage was
600 milligrams of aspirin daily,
which is kind of a prohibitive amount.
So to that end, there is a newer iteration looking
at lower doses of which we're participating, so hopefully we'll have more answers
related to that. For right now, we recommend
161 milligrams of aspirin
to all Lynch syndrome carriers.
Yep.
Thank you. Oh.
Yeah. Sir John
Burn gave his little take on this yesterday, and his paper's going to be out-
Yeah
... in a couple of days. So we'll all be doing the lower aspirin.
Great review. The extracolonic screening also is a very
sensitive point.
Yeah.
That's an aspect we've been interested in, and we have
obviously technologies available to go after the
urothelial cancer screening with ctDNA.
Sir John made a comment yesterday. I was curious your comment.
He was having a fit about annual colonoscopy in Lynch
syndrome and giving arguments why Europe is
moving more towards two and three-year.
If Henry Lynch was there, he would have strangled him.
So I
was curious your reaction.Part of this may have to do with the biology,
right? And I'm just curious-
That's right
... the interplay with aspirin, the interplay with modifiers.
We've looked so carefully at modifiers in the germline
in breast cancer and in prostate cancer, and yet in Lynch
syndrome
haven't really-
That's right
... looked as carefully at it. But I'm curious
how you take into account this trend to
pushing back screening in Europe.
I actually think we have kind of skewed
the presentation of Lynch syndrome because in 2000, we
initiated colon cancer screening with colonoscopy.
So we probably prevented plenty of maybe Lynch
syndrome-associated colon cancers in family through
prevention, through polypectomy, and have skewed.
I see MLH1 families coming in with no colon cancers in the
family in patients who really
promote screening behaviors, and there's a huge uptake.
I'm really wary of pushing out screening in
MLH1 carriers. They're more likely to develop
interval cancers, and they're the ones that are thought
to have possibly a progression that isn't the typical
adenoma sequence. So for those carriers, I
wouldn't do it.
For MSH6 and PMS2, most definitely.
For MSH6, they need to start screening later.
I think we're over-screening the lowest of high-risk
individuals. That's why I'm more of a proponent of a multimodal
approach that really focuses
on
using different technologies. I also think it's really important to look at the
family history. When they're with us, we've got a captive audience,
especially for the extra colonics, and how we fine-tune that
cancer screening.
Which are particularly in MSH2.
Correct. And it's a high burden. So
maybe a really well
multi-cancer early detection test.
I'm not necessarily advocating for that because we do still
perform a lot of the screening that they need.
The upper endoscopies, we can't not do.
I think with the urothelial cancers, which are a huge burden for both men and
women and also in younger ages, that I think
microsatellite instability testing, and there's some data from the
Newcastle group. I don't know if John spoke about it, but it's very
impressive, and I think we're going to be validating in some cohorts
here in the US.
Yeah. So it definitely has changed over time, and I think it will
continue to evolve. And I also think the exposome is something
to think about in these families as well.
Lots of work to be done. Thank you.
Well, Dr. Savage and I did not coordinate, but I'm so grateful
that she gave her talk first because it really does
set up this conversation. So I am a head
neck surgeon, and when I was training, head neck cancer
happened in people who had long histories of
tobacco exposure, usually smoking cigarettes, usually in
combination with use of alcohol. In my
lifetime, we've seen an emergence of a whole new category of head neck
cancer, which is HPV positive head neck cancer.
But because
children with Fanconi anemia
died largely before they became adults,
we never heard about Fanconi anemia.
We never saw a patient with head neck cancer who had
Fanconi anemia. And I remember I was with Alan D'Andrea
at a meeting, and we were suddenly aware that
people with Fanconi anemia were developing head neck
cancer, and we thought, "Oh, it's HPV." But it's
not HPV. So now I'm going to tell you a little bit about
my journey, both as a clinician and as an investigator, trying to
understand this problem that is extraordinarily urgent.
I am part of the Fanconi Cancer Foundation, formerly Fanconi Anemia
Research Foundation, and we coordinate a virtual
tumor board for families and clinicians.
Most clinicians are seeing their first and probably only patient
with head neck cancer who has Fanconi anemia.
They don't know what to do. And, I think it's not
unfair to say that we have at least one tumor board a week
serving clinicians all over the world.
This is an extraordinarily
increasing and urgent problem. So, as I mentioned,
these children
typically presented early in life. Dr.
Savage described many of the different phenotypes that they
would present with,
characterized by germline defects in DNA repair genes
that have been very well-characterized over the last 20 to 30
years. And sometimes we will see an adult
patient, no diagnosis of Fanconi anemia.
They have head neck cancer. They're given platinum
or radiation without an awareness of the need for dose reduction.
They'll have an extraordinary toxic reaction, and then they will go through
the diagnostic process and turn out to have a form of
Fanconi anemia.
So what you saw in Dr. Savage's talk is
all the data. The good news is that bone marrow
transplant or hematopoietic stem cell transplant has
saved the lives of these children, and they're now living into
their teenage years and adulthood.
The consequence, though, is they have an
extraordinarily high risk for developing solid
tumors. And I'm going to say this...
clearly because it's still
not understood at all. Why would
these people get squamous cell carcinoma of the oral
cavity? We do not understand this.
We have lumped head neck cancer as one etiology over
the years. Maybe now it's HPV positive versus HPV
negative, but what is it about the mucosa of
the oral cavity that puts these individuals at such an
extraordinarily high risk? It's 500, 600, 700
fold increased incidence. We don't understand it, but it says something that is
something fundamentally important about DNA repair
in oral carcinogenesis, and we simply don't understand this very
well. So in addition, the vast majority of the
patients in our virtual tumor board have head neck cancer, but
increasingly we are seeing individuals with esophageal cancer,
vulvar cancer. Last week it was liver cancer, the week before it was breast
cancer. So it's more commonly head neck cancer, but it's certainly
not isolated to head neck cancer.
And as emphasized by Dr. Savage, our treatment
options are profoundly limited,
and there are a couple of understandable limitations.
Even though I am bombarded with these individuals in
my academic now practice, it's a very small patient
population. It's maybe 1,000 people right now
in the United States living with Fanconi anemia.
And so clinical trials historically have
excluded any individual with this kind of
inherited predisposition syndrome.
And to my knowledge, the only trial that
has ever been implemented for head neck cancer in Fanconi anemia
patients is happening in Europe, spearheaded by
investigators in Spain, and it's looking at an oral
EGFR tyrosine kinase inhibitor. And we'll talk a little bit about the
opportunities and some of the challenge with picking one agent
for what I'm going to show you is an incredibly heterogeneous population.
We've learned the hard way that they cannot get
systemic chemotherapy, that
is way too toxic. There are ways to deliver radiation.
We've had some very dedicated radiation oncologists who have worked out a
dose reduction schema or a dose testing schema.
Many of these patients are trying protons
to a largely beneficial effect. We've reviewed all the cases in the
literature, and it is safe to give radiation, but one must be
aware of the toxicity and proceed appropriately.
And the animal models simply don't
exist. They're very limited. They aren't readily
extrapolatable to most clinical settings, and we don't have any clinical
trial data. So I'm going to tell you about what we
decided to do. So I am here with my research
partner, Dan Johnson, who's in the audience, and Agata
Smogorzewska, who is an investigator, a pathologist, a
scientist from Rockefeller. Rockefeller had housed one of
the original databases, family collections of
patients with Fanconi anemia. And what Agata did with a team of
international collaborators, it probably took 20 years to
accumulate these specimens. So I had the privilege and honor of being one of
the leaders of the head neck cancer TCGA effort.
So when Agata was trying to accumulate samples and
do essentially a TCGA on head neck cancer
in Fanconi patients, we had a lot of deep
conversations, and the first expectation was that
these cancers would be different.
And I'm going to cut to the chase, they're not.
Other than the
penetration of the germline defects in DNA repair, most of these
individuals have defects in FANC A.
The compendium of genetic
alterations in the head neck cancers from Fanconi patients
are exactly like the head neck cancers from patients with
sporadic head neck cancer. So no smoking gun, no obvious
target. So what we have done in our lab for decades
is we figured out a long time ago that our cell lines were
so distantly related to the patients that we were treating that we needed to
develop new models. So we've developed over the years probably close to
100 patient-derived xenografts from sporadic head neck
cancers. There were no such models for Fanconi anemia
patients, so we decided with support from the Fanconi Cancer Foundation
to try to develop, collect these models, and do some
experiments to give us some clue as to the
relative homogeneity, heterogeneity of this population, and maybe
give us an inclination as to possible therapies that could
be translated into the clinic. So we did this just the way
we did with sporadic patients.
We had to get the tumor right away. It had to be processed very precisely,
and then we had to implant them into the mice and propagate them.
And I'm now going to report on the models that we have generated and
characterizedSo the first three models
were from three different individuals.
Patient one and patient three
were very young. Patient one was 13
and subsequently succumbed to the head-neck cancer before we could
even really characterize the tumor and do the experiments.
Patient three also died from a recurrent head-neck
cancer, an individual in his early 30s.
Patient two, however, is still alive.
And because this is such a small community, I've met this patient.
I've met his family. He's already had two head-neck
cancers. And so there was somewhat a sense of an urgent need
to be able to identify a potential target for when
he develops his recurrence or his third primary
tumor. So the first thing we asked is, even though platinum
is contraindicated for patients with Fanconi anemia, is
it possible that they would be exquisitely sensitive and we
could find a low dose of platinum that would be
tolerated and also effective? And I think the answer
is maybe. I'm not sure. So clearly, there was a dose
response to platinum among all three
of our Fanconi anemia PDX models. And we've
characterized platinum response across a larger number of sporadic
head neck cancer models, and I think you can appreciate that
two of the Fanconi models are by far
the most sensitive to platinum of all the models that we tested.
One is intermediate, but it is possible that that could be tested.
It would have to be done really carefully. We have to think of the right platform.
Would this be an N of one platform? It probably could not be a broad
clinical trial. And of course, what we're encountering week in
and week out with the clinicians is we're so wired as clinicians to
do no harm and to not give a treatment that we know is going to be associated
with toxicity. But the consequence is we don't give any treatment at
all, and that is why these patients virtually all
eventually die of their head and neck cancer.
So I started studying epidermal growth factor receptor.
We now know it's an established therapeutic target for
sporadic head neck cancer. The monoclonal
antibody cetuximab has been FDA approved for 20
years. And it's usually given in lieu of platinum in patients
who can't tolerate platinum, and it's variably used all over the
world. We never have been able to identify
predictive biomarkers for cetuximab.
20% of the patients with sporadic head neck cancer will respond.
It doesn't appear to have anything to do with the EGFR dose,
expression level, status. But we asked the question, maybe it's a little
bit different for Fanconi patients.
So I think you can appreciate that when we profiled EGFR
expression in the three tumors, it was
only really expressed to any substantial degree in
model number one.
And we're going to talk a little bit more about the high phosphorylated AKT
in model number three. I kind of went over this quickly, but
model number three has a canonical mutation in the PIK3CA
oncogene. So it's not at all surprising that they have activation of
phosphorylated AKT. And indeed, when we looked at the
response to cetuximab across these models, model
number one, expressing very high levels of EGFR, was exquisitely
sensitive to cetuximab, whereas model two and model three were
completely resistant. So when patient number
two recurs, we're not going to recommend cetuximab for this
patient. It doesn't make any sense at all.
And I will also tell you that there are about 12 case reports in the
literature of Fanconi patients with head neck cancer getting
cetuximab. None of them were cured with the therapy, but they
all tolerated the therapy. And it's possible one could think
about a clinical trial that the conditions might be
enriched for a cure, because by the time patients get to a clinical trial,
it's usually a phase one population, and cure is highly
unlikely.
And again, we see heterogeneity of cetuximab
sensitivity compared to the sporadic model.
So this model of Fanconi is the third most sensitive
model to cetuximab. In contrast, the other two
patients with Fanconi, they were completely resistant to cetuximab.
So even though these are only three models, they're the only ones in the
literature, and I think heterogeneity was a theme, and I think what it says
to me is any
trial that we do in Fanconi patients, we have to find the
right balance between understanding it's a rare disorder and the
patients are rare or less common, and they're going to be
heterogeneous. So developing a precision medicine approach in this condition
is going to be challenging, but I think a really important guiding light.
So in addition, biochemically, cetuximab in the model where it was
active did what it's supposed to do in terms of decreasing PARP
expression as well as phosphorylated EGFR
expression and total EGFR downregulation.
Now again, back to model three. So this has a canonical
PIK3CA mutation. I believe it's of the helical domain
E545K, and again, it has phosphorylated
AKT. Now I will tell you that Alpelisa,
BYL719, which is FDA approved for a subset of breast
cancers who have certain activating mutations, it is
not standard of care for head neck cancer.
It has only been tested in a very limited way.
The future of this drug for sporadic head neck cancer is
uncertain. But you can see that in this particular model,
there was a response to BYL alone. There was no
response to cetuximab because remember, it's insensitive.
But when we combine cetuximab and BYL, which is a tolerable
combination in a patient with Fanconi anemia, there appeared to be a
more
significant anti-tumor response.
Again, so if
the next patient has a PIK3CA mutation,
one could consider BYL probably in combination with
cetuximab based on this kind of
data.We then started asking the question about
the tyrosine kinase inhibitors because we knew this trial was happening
in Europe, and we thought, well, maybe there are other EGFR family members, a
pan-EGFR inhibitor or an EGFR
HER2 inhibitor could be active because
afatinib is the drug that's being used in the European trial.
And indeed, we saw that in the tumor that had high
EGFR, it also had high levels of HER2 and HER3.
So they then tested the EGFR TKI dacomitinib, which is FDA
approved in non-small cell lung cancer and being tested in head neck
cancer. And indeed, similar to cetuximab, there was an
exquisite dose response in
model number one with high expression of the targets.
Model number two, completely insensitive.
And interestingly, even though there's no EGFR, there may be lower
levels of the other family members, and there's some activity of the drug
in model number three.
And in dacomitinib, just like cetuximab,
biochemically associated with this activity,
also there was loss of PARP and downregulation of
EGFR phosphorylation, as we would expect.
So biochemical evidence of activity.
But what do we use for this multi-resistant model number two?
And remember, this is a young man who is living with Fanconi
anemia being screened. Luckily, we don't have to do
colonoscopy of the oral cavity, so the burden for screening the oral cavity
is really quite low, and we're used to doing it.
But we did some profiling collaboration with our colleagues at Oregon
Health Sciences University and found that surprisingly, model
number two had high expression of Bcl2, not a known
target in sporadic head neck cancer.
So when we looked at both Bcl2 and BCLXL in this model, it was
clearly upregulated, certainly compared to the other two models.
So we just did the experiment. Venetoclax has not been
tested in head neck cancer. It is FDA approved, of
course, for lymphoma. But you can see that in
this highly resistant model from this individual's stool
alive, there's activity. So what we hope is that if and when
this patient develops their next head neck cancer or a recurrence of their
prior head neck cancer, this could be considered.
There's no reason why this drug could not be well-tolerated in the setting
of Fanconi anemia. So I think I've taken you on a little
journey to just suggest that when we go out of our way and
try to create highly relevant preclinical models from
patients with rare diseases but who are at extraordinarily
high risk of developing a relatively common cancer, it's
worth the investment because we can learn an awful lot.
I think that comprehensive genomic proteomic analysis will help
us figure out which agents to use for which patients.
In the meantime, we're still assuming that one size fits all, which is faulty
logic for all cancer patients likely.
But I think what we now see is there's evidence that expression of
EGFR and its family members may be predictive biomarkers for
EGFR inhibitors. PIK3CA mutations may be predictive
biomarkers for a PI3 kinase pathway inhibitor.
And in the individuals who have high levels of expression of Bcl2
family members, venetoclax off-label should be
considered. So I want to stop by acknowledging all my
colleagues and collaborators, and I'm happy to take questions.
Thank you, Dr. Grandis. That was really beautiful.
And I have to also thank you for your review that you've recently published
on treatment. I used it in clinic a month ago.
Kara Maxwell from Penn. So I'm wondering, I have a couple questions on this.
It seems that the models are obviously
really helpful in this space, and given this is such a rare patient population, it
seems actually doable to have sort of patient avatar models.
Do you think it has to be in the mouse, or
have you guys tried to do organoids? Do they recapitulate it?
And then my second question is, is there a mechanism for those of us who very
rarely see these patients but see them to sort of get you tissue?
Absolutely. So those are fabulous questions. Thank you so much.
So yes, there is a whole group at
Columbia University that is now part of our collaboration.
In addition to our lab historically creating the PDX
models, they are now creating the organoid models, so
hopefully there will be less cumbersome models.
We're also really happy to share, and hopefully we can do this through
the support of the SCF. So anyone who wants to work on these models, there's some
other models in the pipeline.
And what I'd really love to say is that specimens are
critical. So there's two efforts that are supported and
participate in all of these virtual tumor boards.
Number one is Agata's lab at Rockefeller.
So any model that comes out where she or her
laboratory members can get to, I kid you not, they get on trains, they get on
airplanes, they go to the operating room, they get the models.
They are so precious. And so that is a really important mechanism.
And I think as you alluded to, Dr. Savage, we have now
support a study at the NIH. So now we
are
asking all of the FA patients and their families to
go to the NIH, where they get comprehensive screening,
comprehensive testing. So we are sharing the models across
institutions because what's really interesting to me as an adult cancer
doctor is thatThe community really
rallied around centers of excellence for the treatment of the
childhood bone marrow disorders.
And for whatever reason, they were Minnesota and Cincinnati.
But when adults start presenting with their cancers, they're
everywhere, and they may or may not be really
open to their parents dictating how they get their care.
And I've really come over the last 10 years, I have the privilege to get to know
these people. And guess what? They're normal teenagers and young adults,
and they don't want to deal with this.
And so what we're really trying to do is reduce the barriers
to including them. There's now soon to be an open
prevention trial. It's not a predictive prevention trial because it was a little
bit difficult to identify the agents.
I believe we're looking at metformin versus celecoxib.
But I think if you ever thought about cancer prevention,
it's really these individuals with these phenotypes that
deserve to be on an oral agent
that is safe, non-toxic, and theoretically can prevent the cancer from
occurring. Because I think the message is, once these cancers develop, we're
just chasing it. And I can't tell you how heartbreaking it is to have worked
with patients over these last decades who have really
refused the extensive surgery. I'm reminded of a pediatrician
who had an extensive cancer. She had a young child.
She was not interested in having a
laryngopharyngectomy, and she subsequently died of her cancer.
So what we're recommending is awful treatment, but if you don't get the
awful treatment, you die.
Yeah. No, great
presentations. Ken Offit from New
York. This is the Human Models of Mouse Cancer session.
I know Agata's been looking in the lab at Veneta Klaks, just across the board,
not in these specific-
Yeah
... targeted PI3 case.
These patients get transplanted.
Is there a model system where you could think
of a prophylactic
intervention,
say, with a shut down BCL2 or some
intervention during that window to get
ahead? Because once you've got these, and I've seen these cases, it
is very difficult in terms of the management.
But we don't know who will develop them.
Yeah. You raise a really important...
So what I've also understood, getting to know these communities of
pediatric hematologists who treat these patients is the
spirit of collaboration is sometimes more theoretical than actual.
And also, getting these kids
through these transplants is really heroic.
And at the end of the recovery, the last thing people want to do is
think of more treatment. So there's some real social and cultural barriers, and I
think the mouse models, because of their limitations, it's really hard to
have convincing biological data and say, "This is the drug
that we think you should take, and we should study it." So there was a prevention
study
done out of Cincinnati and quercetin, and I
can, I think, comfortably say I don't know what it meant.
Because when we do our research in a silo,
and we don't
really embrace what we don't know, and we don't consider precision
approaches, we end up with a conclusion that it
was probably safe, but I don't know if it actually prevented anything.
But we're really trying hard to burn down those barriers and build bridges, but
it's a really important question. Dr. Savage.
Thanks. I wanted to actually take a minute and just kind of
flip things. So we study cancer predisposition syndromes, and we're
very obviously dedicated to the people who have those disorders.
One of the big reasons that I study those
disorders is to say, what are we learning from these disorders,
and how do we apply it to the general population?
So
I would love to hear your thoughts on
what you're learning now in Fanconi anemia head and neck
cancer
could or maybe could not be applied to all of those other patients
that you've seen and taken care of over all the years with
what we would consider general population head and neck cancer.
Yeah. Beautiful question, and I kind of alluded to it in part of the talk.
So number one, heterogeneity. Just because a
cancer is arising in a patient who has a history of smoking doesn't mean
it's all the same. And for
all of my life until today,
if you want to
ask a question about
molecular characterization of head and neck cancer, you can't unless
you do a prospective trial. Because even as these molecular tumor boards
have grown up in institutions, because of the
heterogeneity of how we approach it, the perception that insurance won't pay for
it, we really have so little information outside the
TCGA of the molecular characterization of
sporadic head neck cancer. But the bottom line is we've learned that it's
heterogeneous. And number two, and this is my rallying cry
because I'm not really in a position to take this on, it's a disease of DNA
repair. What these patients are telling us,
dyskeratosis congenita, Fanconi anemia, it's like ringing
a bell loud and clear that we have not studied
the origins of oral
epithelial transformation. We blame it on tobacco, but maybe it's just
accelerated by tobacco in some cases, but it's fundamentally a disease of
DNA repair, and we have not really tackled that. But thank you for the question.
Hey, thank you. Great talk. I had one quick question and perhaps a long
shot. Is there any correlation between the subtype of Fanconi anemia that the
patient has and then the somatic mutational landscape of their tumor?
That is a question that would probably be in the Nature paper that Agata
published about two years ago, but I believe the answer may be
difficult to know because they're almost all FANK.
Thank you.
Okay.
All right. Well, thank you, everybody. Enjoy San Diego.